Tommi Lehren gets a drink thrown on her
president Trump goes after the deep
state and the City of Seattle decides to
bankrupt itself i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
it's a tweet storm day for president
Trump category-five tweet storm from the
president so we'll get into that in just
a second first I want to say thanks to
our sponsors over at Indo Chino so you
want to look like James Bond but you
don't want to pay James Bond at prices
over at savoia or Savile Row or never
it's called instead go to Indo Chino
Indo chinos the world's largest
made-to-measure menswear company they've
been featured in major publications
including GQ Forbes and Fast Company if
you don't look great in a suit you need
something that looks tailored and you
can't do that if you go to a local
department store and get something off
the rack instead go over to Indo Chino
they make suits in shirts made to your
exact measurements for a terrific fit
guys love the selection of high quality
fabrics the option to personalize all
the details including your lapel lining
and monogram so here's how it works you
visit a showroom their shop online in
indochina comm you pick your fabric you
choose your customizations you submit
your measurements and you wait for your
custom suit to arrive in just a few
weeks you can either go to their
showroom physically as I did in Beverly
Hills or you can order it online and
when it comes it should fit you like a
glove if not they will help you out my
listeners can get any premium Indo Chino
suit for just 379 bucks at Indo Chino
comm when entering Shapiro at checkout
that's 50% off the regular price from
made-to-measure premium suit shipping is
free Indo Chino Comm promo code Shapiro
for any premium suit just 379 bucks and
free shipping it's an incredible deal
for a suit they'll fit you better than
anything you got in a closet right now
Indo Chino Comm promo code Shapiro to
let them know that we sent you by the
way before we begin I also want to say
our tickets are running out very quickly
over at our events Dallas and Phoenix I
believe we are almost sold out in Dallas
we are approaching sold out in Phoenix
so go over to Daley wired.com slash
events if you want to buy a ticket to
our live podcast that we will be doing
in August it should be a blast and I
look forward to seeing you there okay so
president Trump is gaining in the polls
the polls right now look good for
president Trump there's a poll yesterday
that came out and showed the Republicans
had a generic ballot six point lead in
the congressional election now that is
an outlier there's no question that's an
outlier the poll average still has
Republicans down about four points that
said there has been a slow but
incremental increase in Republican vote
share in the Congressional ballot for
the last several months and the question
is why meanwhile the Rasmussen tracking
poll has President Trump up around 50%
even if you don't believe Rasmussen he's
in the mid-40s his polls have also been
trending in the right direction and the
question again
is why and I think that the answer lies
in the fact that so many on the Left
have decided to just treat people with
whom they disagree in deplorable fashion
the latest example of this is Tommy
Lehren ok so Tommy Lehren goes out to
brunch with her mom and a bunch of
people decide to scream at Tommy Lehren
and then throw drinks on her so here is
what it here's what it sounded like
so then person who's tossing a drink at
Tommy Lin for no reason because you're
so cool cuz you tossed a drink at Tommy
Lennon for the great sin of going to
brunch with her mother now you don't
have to be a Tommy Lynn fan to
understand that this is awful behavior
it's just garbage behavior but that's no
shock because folks on the Left have
been engaging in garbage behavior
throughout the campaign cycle you know
we tend to forget a lot of the things
that happen in 2016 because there was so
much that went on in 2016 but there were
trump rallies where people legitimately
showed up and did violence to trump
supporters wasn't Trump supporters doing
violence to Hillary Clinton supporters
it was Hillary Clinton supporters in
many cases doing violence to trump
supporters other were cases obviously
very well publicized of people hitting
dissenters inside Trump meetings and all
the rest but if you're talking about
widespread violence wide scale violence
I believe there was a rally in San Jose
where violence broke out there was the
rally in Chicago that had to be
cancelled because of violence outside
the Democrats have decided to go
full-scale 1968 and this sort of
behavior is not going to help their
cause now maybe this person feels
they're gonna be cheered on social media
for having thrown a glass of water at
Tommy leerin but I just don't know what
you gain through all of the same thing
is happening over at Harvard so the
Harvard alumni from 20 from 2003 they
used their alumni notes to attack Jared
Kushner so according to media I once
every five years this has been done
since the 19th century Harvard alumni
right class notes informally referred to
as the red book to keep in touch with
one another the red book consists of big
life updates such as work marriages and
children in this year's red book for the
class of 2003 15 years after graduation
these updates are interspersed with
attacks on Kushner according to the
Boston Globe one classmate named Sofia
Makris wrote shame on you Jared Kushner
another one named John Sherman said I
for one I'm actually glad a class of o3
finally has a real-life fascist among us
who says Harvard isn't diverse first of
all I know Jared Kushner is not a
fascist this is asinine according to the
globe the aim in part of the disparaging
class notes a select cushion or know
that her service in the Trump White
House will have lasting consequences
resulting in his potential ostracization
from a valuable social network of his
peers hey Jared Kushner is relatively
independently wealthy meaning like worth
hundreds of millions of dollars I really
don't think he cares very much whether
these narrow do wells from his Harvard
class of 2003 don't like him Shonda
Prescott Weinstein is another
of the class of 2003 she expressed
discouragement that only a fraction of
her classmates decided to call out
Kushner in their entries she said he was
in Jerusalem with his wife while people
were being massacred
I feel so emotional about that first of
all who cares how you feel who cares how
you feel why would Jordan Kushner sit
around wondering how some girl he
probably never met when he was at
Harvard cares about the movement of the
embassy to Jerusalem says people were
being massacred he is a person who is
doing horrible things as a black woman
and a Jewish woman I think it's
disgusting
he's not alone in doing these disgusting
things but he's certainly one of the
active participants I think it's
emblematic of Harvard culture that
people didn't want to call him out I
think people thought it was rude and
didn't want to be rude but I think
genocide is rude and I was happy to be
rude so first of all what happened
obviously on the Gaza border was not
genocide it was come out tossing up a
bunch of terrorists to get killed and
putting them behind civilians in order
to get civilians killed but again it
done it demonstrates the utter scorn and
hatred that so many folks on the Left
seemed to have for anybody on the right
by virtually any measure Jared Kushner
is one of the more moderate members of
the Trump administration the attempt to
turn Jared Kushner into some sort of
fascist crazy person and then to call
him out in the Harvard red book which is
supposed to be for like sending each
other nice notes demonstrative of the
fact that the left has become so nasty
toward people with whom it disagrees
that they are actually alienating people
into the moderate Center or to the right
that's the reason that Trump is gaining
in the polls and the Democrats just keep
campaigning further and further to the
left and Meghan McCain she came out
yesterday and she's on the view and she
said you know I'm on the view I'm so
sick of people on the Left submitting
the Planned Parenthood is the number-one
issue for all women why are you playing
this identity politics game or if I
disagree with you it's because I must
disagree with all women because all
women deeply care about abortion we've
talked about this many times on show for
me my women's issues foreign policy
number one two three four five yeah when
the idea that like plans parent for
women in America there are issues there
are issues that are specific to women
and women legislators are more likely to
introduce legislation that specifically
benefit women and that's just a step
elections with that message
you it is not going to be the blue ok
Meghan McCain is exactly right here the
blue wave that was supposed to crest in
November
is actually petering out pretty far from
shore here and again the reason for that
is the antipathy that so many folks on
the left hold for people on the right
it's also thanks to the cultural
hegemony that is that is experienced by
folks on the left at the same time you
see people throwing glasses of water at
Tommy Lera and Harvard alumni trying to
share it shame Jared Kushner and folks
on the left implying that everybody on
the right hates women and all this kind
of stuff at the same time you have this
nice warm cocoon of culture that has
been created specifically for folks on
the left so it was revealed over the
last couple of days the Barack and
Michelle Obama will work both in front
of and behind the camera in a multi-year
production deal with Netflix hey listen
I love Netflix I'm a subscriber to
Netflix I'm a subscriber tom is on prime
there's a lot of material they generate
on Netflix that I am NOT a big fan of
but let's be frank about this do you
think they would ever consider doing a
deal with george w bush like a
faith-based deal to make faith-based
movies with george w bush of course not
of course not there's a reason that
YouTube helped sponsor The Young Turks
but YouTube will D monetize dave rubin
there is a reason that all of these
major media companies are happy to side
with the left while exercising the right
according to cnn.com the unique pack was
announced on monday the first content
from the Obamas will appear in 2019 at
the earliest according to a person
involved in the deal Netflix did not
specify a timeline but the company's
announcement of the deal said the Obamas
will produce a diverse mix of content
including the potential for scripted
series unscripted series docu-series
documentaries and features now you might
ask what does Barack Obama or Michelle
what do these people know about
producing film the answer is of course
they know nothing what do these people
know about great narrative art the
answer of course is they don't know
anything but because the people of
Netflix are so blown away by the
celebrity of the Obama the Obama clan
they've decided that it's time to give
them a multi-picture deal you know many
people struggle in Hollywood to ever get
one picture from Netflix and Netflix is
giving this entire broad spectrum deal
to the Obamas for no reason other than
Barack Obama was a Democratic president
that they admire and love that warm
cocoon is what's driving away so many
Americans according to against CNN
sometimes the former President and First
Lady will be on camera as hosts or
moderators the source said on condition
of anonymity in other cases they will
stay behind the scenes as producers
financial terms were not disclosed the
Obamas are giving that
it's valuable content that many of the
streaming services 125 million members
may want to watch and netflix is giving
the Obamas valuable platform to stay
visible in their post White House years
I love that editorializing from CNN
you know the ratings are gonna be on the
is Obama series zip you know who
actually wants to watch the Obama's some
more
no one hey there was a movie that came
out about Barack and Michelle Obama's
first date it did like one dollar of
business because no one cares but the
whole point here is that when you feel
ensconced in a cultural ivory tower
where everyone loves you everyone thinks
like you it is very easy to look down on
the people outside the ivory tower and
say look at those rubes look at those
charlatans all those people like Tommy
Lehren look at these people who like
Donald Trump what a bunch of morons
let's just sit up here and spit well
hawk loogies from the front of the ship
just like the characters in Titanic
that'll be our new thing we'll spit down
on the crowd below Barack Obama said we
hope to cultivate and curate the
talented inspiring creative voices who
are able to promote greater empathy and
understanding between peoples and help
them share stories with their entire
world yeah because if there's one thing
I think when I think the Obamas I think
empathy for their political opponents
whom they slandered routinely and
repeatedly throughout their political
career these are the creatures of
empathy but this is the whole point
people can see themselves as empathetic
so long as they are members of a tribe
because they look at other members of
their political tribe and they say well
I care about those people and those
other people I don't care about that's
because they're inherently uncaring
they're inherently intolerant it's okay
to throw water at Tommie leerin because
after all she's a bad person she doesn't
care about us so why should I care about
her when you don't see each other as
brothers and sisters when you see each
other instead as enemies it's pretty
easy to make a case that the other
person should be treated like garbage
it's easy to make the case the Jared
Kushner as a fascist when you haven't
spent any time with Jared Kushner or
even looked at what he's done it's very
easy to make these cases but you know
that's that's the leftist tended to do
and the American people are responding
pretty badly to that whole spiel they're
responding pretty badly and they're also
resonating to what President Trump has
to say in response to that which I'll
get to in just one second first I want
to say thanks to our sponsors over at
helix sleep so there's nobody on the
planet who is just like you thank God
because who would want to of you but you
should have a mattress that is tailored
to you we have a huge sleep mattress at
our house the way it works is you go
online and you take a sleep
quiz basically it's and it uses a
proprietary algorithm to determine what
is the best mattress for you do you want
a firm mattress a soft mattress a
breathable mattress one that is more
heat absorbent do you want that do you
want what size mattress do you want do
you and your spouse actually want to
have two different settings on your
sides of the mattress they do all of
this then they send you the mattress in
the mail it comes in a big box and you
unruhe and you unpack the box and it
just inflates right there in front of
you and the mattress is good to go it is
incredibly comfortable we've been using
it in my house for years we got rid of a
more expensive mattress and moved it
actually to the back room specifically
because this mattress is so good helix
sleep is just fantastic and they have
all new pillows which are fully
adjustable so you can achieve perfect
comfort regardless of sleep position or
body type helix sleep has thousands of
five-star reviews plus you get a hundred
nights to try them out so go to helix
sleep calm slash been right now I get up
to 125 dollars toward your mattress
order that's helix sleep calm /ban for
up to 125 bucks off your mattress order
helix sleep calm slash been use that
slash pen so that they know that we sent
you okay so in the face of all these
people who seem to hate you just because
of your political points of view it's no
wonder so many people are resonating to
President Trump because now if people
are enemies you want the biggest hammer
you can find and that's what President
Trump has been doing so president Trump
comes out yesterday he's at pro-life
gala and he's slapping and all of his
opponents including Nancy Pelosi Pelosi
of course you'll remember essentially
said that Trump was wrong to call
members into ms-13 animals the great
ironic story yesterday of course is that
there was an ms-13 member who was
arrested whose actual name his nickname
was animal which is pretty hilarious but
in any case here was Trump going after
Nancy Pelosi at a susan b anthony list
dinner just the other day Nancy Pelosi
came out in favor of ms-13 that's the
first time I've heard that she wants
them to be treated with respect as do
other Democrats that's not going to be
happening we're not going to release
violent criminals into our country now
as I've been saying for a long time the
most effective tactic to take in
politics is not necessarily the best
tactic to take for the country so I
wrote an entire book called bullies in
2013 the entire premise raised a long
time ago the entire premise
is that the Democrats were spending all
of their time engaged in character
assassination against Republicans and if
Republicans continue to play this game
where they talk to policy alone without
rebutting the character assassination by
attacking character of Democrats than
they would lose Trump took up that
mantle in spades right President Trump
understands character assassination
better than pretty much anyone else in
American public life he's been both the
victim of it and the perpetrator of it
for virtually his entire career and
that's why so many people have flocked
to his banner the reason a lot of people
are supporting President Trump right now
is because you see a lot of people on
the Left and you look at them and
they're and they're yelling at people in
megawhatts
or they are trying to crash the party at
particular Trump events or they're
throwing water at conservative
commentators and people go okay well at
least Trump is fighting back I promise
you that's the number one phrase you get
from from supporters at least he's
fighting back and that is the perception
that he's fighting back and this isn't
to say that Democrats have to surrender
their political principles but if they
actually want to be successful they
might want to think about treating the
American public as potential friends
rather than as current enemies if they
continue to treat them as enemies those
enemies will go look for the best
fighter they can find in the perspective
of a lot of conservatives with
perspective a lot of Americans who don't
like what the left are doing right now
is the same perspective that was
attributed apocryphally to Abraham
Lincoln about ulysses s grant I can't
spare this man he fights so who cares
about Trump's heresies so long as the
dude is slapping the right folks well I
mean what are you gonna do bend over for
all these folks who are throwing water
at you and and yelling at you and taking
out ads in the Harvard alumni newspaper
to target you and calling you a Rueben
an idiot and signing deals with the
Obamas and Netflix it better to have
somebody who fights then somebody who's
not gonna fight properly at all and
that's one of the reasons why I think
the Trump investigation the Trump
Russian investigation is actually not
resounding to Democrats benefit so let's
talk about that for a second Democrats
are very very upset that President Trump
appears to be pushing the DOJ to
investigate the so-called FBI spying
into his campaign as I say I am very
skeptical that the FBI launched a
politically motivated attack on the
Trump campaign during the 2016 election
campaign in order to uncover Russian
collusion and then didn't drop any of
that information the entire campaign
cycle and waited until after the
election cycle in order to start leaking
that information that just doesn't make
a lot of that conspiracy theory does not
watch for me and again
Trumpkin declassify any of that material
at any point well this is not stop
President Trump from going on a Twitter
and so category five president Trump
tweets storm this came out this morning
he says if the person plays very early
into my campaign wasn't a spy put there
by previous administration for political
purposes how come such a seemingly
massive amount of money was paid for
services rendered many times higher than
normal
well apparently the guy who was the
quote-unquote spy was a professor who'd
written a couple of books none of them
very good he was actually the professor
who was the apparent spy is worth noting
was actually considered by Peter Navarro
current trump administration member for
a position inside the Trump
administration after Trump's actual
election he's paid to let use offer like
three thousand dollars for a piece of
writing to write an essay or something
not sure why that is a a giant a giant
overpay in any case Trump continues he
says follow the money the spy was there
early in the campaign and yet never
reported collusion with Russia because
there was no collusion he was only there
to spy for political reasons and to help
crooked Hillary Rinne win just like they
did to Bernie Sanders who got duped
okay now none of this makes any sense so
the spy was there to report on collusion
but he didn't report on collusion so he
was there to spy for political reasons
to help crooked Hillary win but he
didn't help crooked Hillary win because
crooked Hillary lost because none of
this information came out during the
election cycle so that's weird and then
President Trump continues along these
lines
look how things have turned around on
the criminal deep state all caps they go
after phony collusion with Russia a
made-up scam and end up getting caught
in a major spy scandal the likes of
which the country may never have seen
before
what goes around comes around now as I
say if it turns out that the Obama
administration was siccing informants on
the Trump campaign in order to crush the
Trump campaign without any evidence it
is significantly worse than Watergate I
haven't seen the evidence to support
that quite as of yet and then Trump
continues he's really ranting now it is
clear that they had eyes and ears all
over the Trump campaign Judge Andrew
Napolitano he's quoting Napolitano from
Fox & Friends this morning and then he
continues along these lines he says
Spygate could one be one of the
political biggest political scandals in
history well I mean it was one of the
biggest football scandals in history ask
Bill Belichick and then Donald Trump
continues he says trying trumpet should
be happy that the FBI was spying on his
campaign no James clapper I am NOT happy
spying on a campaign would be illegal
and a scandal to boot fair enough James
clapper is an idiot and then he finally
concludes
witch-hunt right all caps would chante
which as soon as he says witch-hunt
i just think of duck hunt and I'm seven
years old again playing my grandmother's
basement and shooting the ducks with the
with the gun right up to the TV so much
on this is like the this has to be the
sixth or seventh time the president
Trump has tweeted out witch hunts and
this of course has prompted great
hilarity on Twitter people tweeting out
actually about duck hunt with the
picture of the Laughing dog there was
somebody who tweeted out a gif of Tom
Cruise descending from the ceiling Ethan
Hunt is there was a rather obscene one
that was going around that I'm sure you
can guess that ends with hunt so there's
that as well yeah look does president
Trump have solid backing for these
accusations no but we're gonna find out
in this investigation you would hope but
the point is this Democrats have decided
that President Trump has no authority to
do any of this and so they've decided
that he is a dictator now two things can
be true at once Trump may not have
support for this position that he was
spied on by the deep state in any
serious fashion and by the same token or
at least not an unjustified fashion and
by the same token when Democrats say
things like Trump is a dictator it's
really stupid so when you have mazie
Hirono who is the democratic senator
from Hawaii saying the Trump is like a
dictator how is he like a dictator we
have a system of checks in what what
what but this is what this is their
routine so you have a president Trump
who has attacked the media he's gone
after the gone after judges who don't
agree with him he's certainly going
after the intelligence community the FBI
a Department of Justice and these are
the kinds of actions taken by people
like erawan in Turkey to charity and the
Philippines and of course the Putin in
in Russia yeah exactly because it all
all three murdered their political
opponents has Donald Trump murdered any
of his political opponents lately I
missed that part see this is the part
where Donald Trump has a gift that is
just keeps on giving and that is that
everybody on the Left will always
overreact to everything he does so what
they should say is President Trump has
no support for any of the things that he
is tweeting and it's a slander on our
intelligence community to suggest that
they were politically motivated in their
investigations into George papadopolis
and Karger page and they should just
stick with that that this guy's talking
nonsense instead they go to he's a
dictator he's like doTERRA tea in the
Philippines who who kills drug dealers
he's like Errol
who do in in prisons and murders his
political opponents like Putin who's
done exactly the same and really really
no wonder Americans are not resonating
to the Democratic message right now no
wonder Democrats are really disheartened
because the data says Makana is not
coming okay Miller is not gonna save you
from Trump okay so in a little while I
want to talk about Democratic policy but
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at zip recruiters so every
business needs great people or you need
better people right now you're
constantly looking to upgrade your staff
that is why you need a zip recruiter zip
recruiter knows there is a smarter way
than just randomly posting jobs on
random sites instead zip recruiter
learns what you're looking for
identifies people with the right
experience and invites them to apply it
for your job these invitations have
revolutionized how you find your next
hire in fact 80% of employers to post a
job on zip recruiter can a quality
candidate through the site in just one
day zip recruiter doesn't stop there
they spot like the strongest
applications you receive so you never
miss a great match the right candidates
are out there and zip recruiter can help
you find them right now my listeners can
try zip recruiter for free so just go to
zip recruiter dot-com slash daily wire
that zip recruiter comm slash daily wire
use that slash daily Wireless they know
we sent you it's the best way to try out
zip recruiter for free it is indeed the
smartest way to hire there's no reason
not to use super career if you are
looking to make your business better and
again we're all looking to make our
business better make our business more
efficient make our business more useful
that is what zip recruiter is for again
eighty percent of employers who post a
job on zip recruiter have a quality
candidate through the site in a day you
could be one of them zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire alright so and what
about Democratic policy so they spends
all of their time ripping on President
Trump and suggesting the President Trump
is on the verge of being taken down and
they're their favorite story now is that
Michael cones business partners and
Evgeny Friedman has agreed to cooperate
as part of a plea deal it is not clear
that this is going to have any
ramifications for Trump in any serious
way according to CNBC Evgeny Friedman
has agreed to cooperate the cooperation
by the taxi King Friedman could spell
very bad news for Cohn who subjects of
an ongoing criminal investigation by
federal prosecutors in New York City the
time suggested that Friedman's
cooperation could be used as leverage to
pressure Cohen to work with the special
counsel but again all of this is
speculation
bottom line is Democrats have nothing
they do not have anything right now to
run on other than just anger just anger
at President Trump they certainly don't
have power
see to run on okay and the latest
indicator the Democrats do not have
policy to run on is the way that they
are wrecking major cities they've
wrecked Los Angeles and they've turtle
they've turned my city into as president
Trump might say a bleep hole yeah the
city of Los Angeles now has 55,000 to
60,000 homeless people who are sleeping
on the streets every single night okay
enough people to fill Dodger Stadium are
sleeping on the streets of Los Angeles
they have not filled the potholes they
have not made the city better they've
not made the city cleaner they've made
the city more crime ridden this is true
across the state of California and it's
not just in Los Angeles it's in Seattle
Seattle is a beautiful city I used to do
a show exclusively in Seattle on a
station Katie th okay now let me tell
you Seattle
gorgeous it is an upper-crust city okay
by incoming is an upper-crust Hippias
growing city it has three major
companies more than that actually that
are located there it has Microsoft
Amazon and Starbucks all of which are
located in the city of Seattle and
Boeing which is located just outside the
city of Seattle Tacoma Seattle area okay
so here's the problem Seattle has
determined that they are so interested
in social justice warrior ring and
they're gonna empty out their city
what's the latest so as you recall last
week Seattle decided on an Amazon tax
maybe it's a head tax the head tax was a
couple of hundred bucks per employee for
companies that make over twenty million
dollars a year and this money was
supposed to go to alleviate the homeless
problem it will not alleviate the
homeless problem because the homeless
problem is created by the fact that if
you won't arrest people who are sleeping
on the streets and if you won't allow
people to build more housing because of
building regulations then you are going
to end up with more homeless people on
the streets and that's especially true
if you implement maybe like a $15
minimum wage which Seattle did a couple
of years ago and in doing so helped
crush a lot of small businesses and
force a lot of people out of jobs well
now they've decided City Seattle City
Council they've decided to go even
further now they're considering an
enormous property tax on all of these
people so according to q13 Fox King
County homeowners which is where Seattle
is located they saw a bump of seventeen
percent in their property taxes in 2017
but now City Council members want to see
property taxes increased even more
council members Lorena Gonzalez and Rob
Johnson are sponsoring the measure which
states the council wants to lift the
limit on regular property taxes in order
to levy additional taxes in 2014 Seattle
voters approved a fifty eight million
dollar levy allowing low-income kids
to go to preschool for free since 2015
the city says the program has allowed
affordable or free preschool to 850
families so just to do that quick
calculation okay that means that there
are 58 million dollars that means that
they have spent to put each of these
preschool families in preschool and I
assume that's about one child per family
$68,000 okay so well done local
government yay local government all you
had to do was spend 58 million dollars
to let sit to give affordable and free
preschool to 850 families it's a sixty
eight thousand dollars per family he
could just sign him a check gang now the
city wants to send hundreds more to
preschool and mayor Jenny Durkins office
is pushing to send high school graduates
to Community College for free so you're
going to establish their socialist
utopia on the back of or a
redistributionist the very least utopia
on the back of major businesses they
will tax out of business the property
tax would amount to on average and not
more than another two hundred and fifty
bucks per year for homeowners now has
any of this alleviated living conditions
in Seattle the answer of course is no
Seattle still has a massive homeless
problem they have tent cities that exist
all over the city Seattle's building
code is seven hundred forty-five pages
the residential building code is another
six hundred and eighty-five pages it's
impossible to build anything in Seattle
the Seattle City Council has focused far
more on Road diets far more on roads
eyes narrowing roads via bike lanes than
on the quality of traffic King County
spent billions of dollars on useless
light rail they allotted something like
fifty billion dollars for a stupid light
rail that nobody cares about but now
they want to bust a homeowners wallet
again after instituting a fifteen dollar
minimum which this is how you empty out
major American cities first you create
building codes because you want to
maintain the pristine aura of the area
then you raise rents because there's
less housing and more support more
demand and less supply then you increase
minimum wage to compensate which drives
out small business then you tax the big
businesses to compensate then they leave
see tax the homeowners to compensate so
they leave this is how you empty out a
major American city Detroit used to be a
booming city and then Democrats got a
hold of it and they turned it to crap
that's not a great shock because this is
what Democrats do with policy this is
what Democrats do with policy and no
wonder they're relying on president
Trump's supposed suppose
out-of-the-box ridiculousness as
president to try and drive them into
victory their policies are not
attractive nothing they are doing right
now is attractive policy and by the way
Barack Obama's agenda is completely
collapsing I mean Donald Trump is
erasing the the Obama agenda one bill at
a time basically the dodd-frank bill is
now being is now being dismantled piece
by piece so according to NBC News the
House voted late on Tuesday to pass a
bill that will change significant
aspects of dodd-frank which is the
banking reform bill introduced after
loose lending and risky measures by
financial institutions led to the
country's worst recession since the
Great Depression since it passed in 2010
the dodd-frank Wall Street Reform
Consumer Protection Act has been the
target of animosity by many
conservatives and the banking industry
right that's because the dodd-frank Wall
Street Reform and Consumer Protection
Act doesn't actually protect consumers
and reform Wall Street in fact in
shrines government bailouts it says that
if there is that much risk that is taken
on by a particular firm the government
has to bail them out it forces a
government bailout so the bill is likely
to become law so dodd-frank of course
was an attempt to reestablish oversight
and control over financial institutions
after the economic meltdown it was a
2,300 page bill it was garbage it
included the creation of the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau which has
not been used for consumer financial
protection but instead has been used for
cronyism by Democrats an attempt to shut
down businesses they don't like it has
led to increased bank reporting
requirements as well as the so-called
Volcker Rule an attempt to separate
hedge funds from they've tried to
reestablish glass-steagall separating
hedge funds from investment banks and
all of the rest I'll talk a little bit
more about that in just a second first
you're gonna have to go over to Daley
wire comm so if you go over to Daley
wire comm you get the rest of this show
live you also get the rest of the
Michael Noel's show live the rest of the
Andrew Clavin show live and you get
special access to tickets at our events
so we have two events that are coming up
in August in Dallas in Phoenix if you
had been a subscriber you would have had
first access to tickets to those events
if not go over to Daley wire.com slash
events right now a couple of tickets are
still available but before we but but it
is also worth noting it is also worth
noting that you can get all sorts of
other goodies when you go there you get
to be part of the mailbag as well now
before I go any further I first want to
say thank you to our sponsors at
stamps.com so these days you can get
pretty much everything you want on
demand so our podcast you can get on
demand right anything you want
any product you want you go on
amazon.com get it on demand so why are
you still going to the post office to
mail letters and packages there's no
reason to do so go to stamps com instead
with stamps calm and get all the amazing
services in the post office right from
your desk 24/7 when it is convenient for
you buy and print official US postage
for any letter any package using your
own computer and printer the mail
carrier picks it up click print mail
you're done could not be easier we use
stamps calm here at the Daily wire
offices saves its loss of time and time
is money so it saves us lots of money as
well we have the the the postage meter
that comes along the digital scale that
allows you to use exactly the right
amount of postage on your letters it
really is a lifesaver
right now use Shapiro and you get a
special offer when you go to stamps com
it includes up to 55 bucks of free
postage a digital scale and a four week
trial go to stamps calm before you do
anything else click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Shapiro that stamps comm
enter promo code Shapiro you that
special deal 55 bucks of free postage
digital scale four-week trial you will
love it we use it our business I'm
getting it from my house as well because
it's that good and I don't feel like
going to the post office and post office
is great I just don't feel like going
there stamps calm is what allows you to
avoid that trip go to stamps calm and
make sure that you get that special deal
when you use promo code Shapiro okay so
as I say it's gonna listen to the
podcast a little bit later for free if
you want to listen to it on iTunes or
SoundCloud or YouTube subscribe loops
review we always appreciate it we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so back to the dodd-frank
bill so according to NBC News the
proposed changes to be called
systemically important and subject to
more regulations banks would need assets
of two hundred and fifty billion dollars
rather than the current fifty billion
dollars that significantly reduces the
number considered too big to fail as I
said dodd-frank one of the worst things
that it did is it enshrined a certain
amount of risk-taking by these banks
basically what they said is that in the
aftermath of the financial collapse all
these banks were terrible actors they
undertaken great risk the reason they
undertook great risk is because of
something we call moral hazard in
economics moral hazard is the idea that
if I pay you to do something stupid or
if you know they're going to pick you up
and brush you off when you do something
stupid they were more likely to do
something stupid so moral hazard is me
saving my son from falling off the back
of a chair okay moral it creates a
certain I should do it because he's my
kid but it creates a certain amount of
moral hazard because now he thinks that
he can stand on the back of the chair
with no real ramifications well the bank
was standing on the back of the chair
and the government picked them up and
brushed them off and dodd-frank instead
of saying listen from now on we're not
doing this anymore there's no more
too-big-to-fail you go bankrupt you go
bankrupt that's the end of it instead
dodd-frank enshrined all of these banks
said if you have 50 billion dollars in
assets well then we will enshrine you as
too big to fail and we will pay you off
and then they said in order to prevent
you from taking these risks we are now
going to regulate you from taking the
risk so you get the downside of too big
to fail and you also get the downsides
of banks that are not willing to
undertake loans that they may not have
taken before unwilling to invest in
projects they may have been willing to
invest in because they were the ones
bearing the risk and not everybody else
so only nine US chartered commercial
bank holding companies would meet the
definition according to data from the
Federal Reserve that B State Street
SunTrust the u.s. division of s HSBC
fifth fifth third key Bank Citizens Bank
those would all be under the limit okay
so that all of those would no longer be
considered too big to fail
the new bill would allow the mid-size
banks to not be under such scrutiny when
it comes to their lending practices many
original supporters of dodd-frank say
and think that this is a rollback
they say that this is really bad because
we want to we want to make sure that
everybody is going to be everybody's
going to be regulated up the wazoo so
banks with under ten billion dollars
could ignore the Volcker rule as I
mentioned the Volcker rule is actually
allows them to deposit funds in
speculation okay the Volcker rule
prevents them from using deposit funds
and
speculation prevents banks from
investing remember when you deposit
money in a bank is typically used for
investments in other projects the
government has cracked down on these
banks the market takes care of all of
these things so long as people do their
research the government involvement in
the banking industry has led to
additional moral hazard and so and and
the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
is one of the worst bureaus in America
it's it's just it's just garbage I mean
it's it's been used to to crack down on
businesses it's been used to to crack
down on particular actors that members
the government don't like hey according
to Diane Katz over at the Heritage
Foundation the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau created by dodd-frank
is living up to its billing as one of
the most powerful and unaccountable
federal agencies ever created after just
18 months and this is she wrote this
shortly after its creation in 2012 and
with the staff exceeding 1,000 and
funding of 600 million dollars the
bureau is restructuring the mortgage
market devising restrictions on credit
bureaus education loans overdraft
policy's payday lenders credit card
plans and prepaid cards amassing
unverified complaints with which to
assail creditors and bankers and they're
basically unelected the folks over at
the CFPB and you remember that earlier
this year there was a big fight over the
CFPB because President Trump wanted to
restate using Mick Mulvaney to clean the
place out and Democrats cried foul
dodd-frank needed to be gutted good for
President Trump for doing that gutting
that indeed is a something that is well
worth while and it looked
bama's legs he's falling apart it should
be falling apart it was a bad legacy but
at least he'll still have his series on
Netflix now meanwhile you're mystified
didn't mentioned this just because it's
an important global issue this Friday
I've been getting a lot of mail from
from Ireland I want to mention this
Ireland is said to hold a referendum to
allow abortion in state hospitals
there's an 8th amendment to their
country's constitution it recognizes the
right to life - for babies from
conception wish to god that we had that
here in the United States instead
there's a referendum that's on the
ballot as a Friday it would repeal that
amendment the government is prepared to
push legislation allowing abortion up to
12 weeks and abortion advocates are
being dishonest
they are suggesting that it would just
be to 12 weeks who would not just be to
12 weeks it would be a lot more like 23
weeks it would look a lot more like
America's abortion laws in a lot of
states all you were required to have an
abortion in Ireland is two physicians
saying the pregnancy would harm the
mental
physical health of the woman in any way
which is a pretty low bar to clear so
this means the babies who have not been
killed up to this point would obviously
be killed in much larger numbers the the
pro-abortion site is being incredibly
disingenuous in Ireland so there been a
bunch of ads that were taken out
featuring Down syndrome babies because
abortion in Western countries has been
used as basically a eugenic
sterilization measure to prevent the
birth of Down syndrome babies well the
folks in Ireland were very upset about
this the Irish Prime Minister Leo Varick
are condemned pro-lifers he said as the
father of a child with Down syndrome I'm
opposed to the propagandistic use of
people like my son and attempts to limit
reproductive rights as has happened in
the Irish debate as well as in the
legislative actions taken in various
American states to outlaw the abortion
of fetuses with Down syndrome so in
other words pay no attention to the fact
that people are actually killing Down
syndrome babies before they're born it's
mean to mention that we shouldn't be
mentioning that social media have taken
their lead from the Irish prime minister
from the Irish president the life news
reports that the Washington Post says
that Facebook announced that it would
stop accepting related advertisements
from groups based outside Ireland so if
you're a pro-life group based outside
Ireland there would be no new ads that
were allowed to go up during this Irish
referendum the restriction testifies to
the depth of concern that foreign
advertising could skew the outcome this
by the way is a great indicator of just
how the left is going to use worries
about Russian collusion and Russian
interference in order to shut down
messages they don't like pro-life groups
including the pro-life campaign the save
the eighth group in the Iona Institute
say that they are being censored by
Facebook and by Google according to the
UK spectator posters of unborn children
have been torn down around Ireland as
well hey this is a deeply important
issue right now the polls show that the
attempt to repeal protection for the
unborn in Ireland is likely to pass that
babies will again be allowed to be
killed in Ireland in large numbers it's
it's a real tragedy that so many folks
who grew up in a civilization that was
predicated on the individual worth of
each human life are now rejecting that
in favour of this bizarre notion of
autonomy that included killing the
unborn in the womb it really is tragic
by the way that the Catholic Church has
not taken a stronger hand in this debate
the Catholic Church obviously still has
an enormous amount of sway in Ireland
but they've stayed out of the debate for
the most part you know we can all
hope and pray that the folks in Ireland
do the right thing and kick back against
this leftist attempt to reinsure an
abortion as some sort of fundamental
right for people who want to kill babies
in the womb okay meanwhile I just have
to comment on this story because the
story is pretty great when
wynton marsalis is of course a very
famous jazz musician and Wynton Marsalis
has come out and he has said that rap
culture sucks okay so he's allowed to
say it because when Marsalis is black of
course but Wynton Marsalis
he says rap culture sucks and he is
exactly correct my words are not that
powerful
I started saying in 1985 I don't think
we should have a musical money and it
had no impact I've said it I've repeated
it I still repeat it to me that's more
that's more damaging than a statue of
Robert ely a statue of Robert Lee took
me I saw the statue my great-uncle hated
it I talked about it but try to talk
somewhere in front of Google black folks
about turning that off okay good for
Wynton Marsalis I mean this is exactly
right now here's the problem if you are
not a black person and you say that the
rap culture is not good for people of
any stripe that rap culture folks
focuses on mistreatment of women use of
drugs materialistic nonsense then this
is considered racist in some sort of way
it is not racist to point out that any
cultural totem that glorifies the vile
is not going to be good for a large
number of people and it seems to me that
there should be more folks across the
political aisle who point out that when
there are rap songs that glorify
disgusting things that this actually has
a cultural impact and more of a cultural
impact by the way as wit Marcel says
than these Confederate statues now I'm
not a huge fan of Confederate statues
because I think that honoring people who
were slaveholders are fighting to uphold
slavery is not a good thing I'm also not
in favor of ripping down those
Confederate statues I have the same
opinion as Condoleezza Rice on this I
think that it is valuable to have those
statues in place specifically so we can
have hard conversations about America's
history how America has changed whether
the statues ought to be up should be an
ongoing conversation I think all of that
is good you know wiping away history I
don't think it is worthwhile but if
you're talking about what's more
damaging to black children rap culture
or that statue of Robert II leave
they've never seen in a park for miles
I don't think that that's much of a
comparison it seems to me that's not
much of a comparison and it turns out
that culture has a relatively large
impact on how people think which is of
course one of the reasons why people are
so intent on on preventing the right
from seizing the cultural high ground
it's why Obama gets a deal with Netflix
it's also why there's a controversy
that's broken out over Ed Sheeran so ed
Sheeran has a song called small bomb and
it came out a few years ago and it's
been used by pro-lifers the reason it's
been used by pro-lifers is because it is
obviously a pro-life song he wrote it
about a woman he knew who'd had a
miscarriage and here is what the song
sounds like
you just smooth pom-pom boy in four
months you're brought to life with my
hair would you happy
[Music]
maybe you needed okay so if you missed
those lyrics he's talking about how this
small bump is a person basically right
here a small bump in four months you
brought to life you might be left with
my hair but you'll have your mother's
eyes I'll hold your body my hands be as
gentle as I can and then he finishes
there's a miscarriage you were just a
small bump unborn for four months then
torn from life maybe you were needed up
there but we're still unaware as to why
okay so a bunch of pro-life groups
started using this as sort of their
anthem so what did Ed Sheeran do he
whined about it so ed Sheeran says he
says you shouldn't use my video to push
a pro-life message because there are a
bunch of people who based on the Irish
referendum were using this for the no
campaign in the Irish referendum and he
said he didn't like that he said I've
been informed my song small bump is
being used to promote the pro-life
campaign I feel it's important to let
you know I've not given approval for
this use it does not reflect what the
song is about it reflects exactly what
the song is about okay the song is about
how it's an unborn child in their
culture matters culture matters and when
people and politics save cultures
upstream from politics this holds true
whether it is bad culture I'm not saying
every rap song is equivalently bad or
all Rapids by a necessity bad I'm saying
that too much of rap culture is about
brutalization of women use of drugs
glorification of crime you know that
hasn't cultural impact and so do songs
like insurance which is why his art is
beyond him okay that what happens in
that song is beyond his capacity to hold
that in because it does promulgate and
what I think is a pretty important
message okay time for a couple of things
I like and then maybe we'll do a thing I
hate so the thing I like today there's a
good book by William Lane Craig William
Lane Craig is a Christian theologian
he's written this massive tome along
with him to remember the name of the guy
who co-wrote it with him about Christian
apologetics
and an arguments on behalf of God a much
shorter version of that is a book called
on guard defending your faith with
reason and precision with a foreword by
Lee Strobel it's a it's a pretty good
I would say guide to sort of how to
argue faith the last third of the book
is great for Christians in terms of
trying to argue the veracity of their
faith I don't buy a lot of the arguments
but that's because I'm Jewish the first
two-thirds of the book is really about
sort of the generic defense of God why
it is not unreasonable to believe that
God exists from a rational point of view
why it is not unreasonable to believe
that you need God in order to create a
moral system he's a good debater William
Lane Craig and if you ever watch a
debate that he did with with Sam Harris
it's it's pretty fascinating to watch
check it out the book is on guard by
William Lane Craig okay other things
that I like so somebody did this
yesterday so yesterday as you recall on
the show I did a this is so stupid
I did I did the lyrics to Kendrick
Lamar's mad city because there was a big
story about how Kendrick Lamar had
brought up a white woman on stage to
sing mad city and then when she sang his
exact lyrics then he got mad at her
because he's the idiot who wrote a bunch
of N words and lyrics and then when she
spoke that me was like no you can't say
that well so yesterday I did the lyrics
without the n-word to demonstrate that
it is unlistenable and somebody promptly
we have lots of listeners somebody
promptly took my read of the lyrics and
inserted it into the song as you can see
this may not be where my talent was
saying like the whole city cook is me
every time a ministry man town where you
from
that's who you know where are you from
where your grandma stay huh Mike
well well there it is it's just so
that's a thing that happened all right
time for some things I hate got nothing
to say about that tempers and things I
hate so here's the thing that I hate
today okay so this is unbelievable and
it just demonstrates Democrats got
nothing I mean lately the Democratic
Left has nothing no ideas nothing the
mayor of West Hollywood California will
join city officials on Wednesday to
present adult film star stormy Daniels
they key to the city and the city
Proclamation according to a media
advisory in the press release city
officials recognized Daniel for her
leadership in the resist movement and
noted that the city has previously
passed resolutions calling for articles
of impeachment to be introduced against
President Trump right because Trump
cares deeply the City of West Hollywood
thinks he ought to be impeached yeah
there's a shopper out of the City of
West Hollywood thinks he ought to be
impeached for people who don't know the
City of West Hollywood very very much
the left they actually fly the rainbow
flag above the City Hall in West
Hollywood so they are very very much
left Daniels according to the press
release has proven herself to be a
Profile in Courage by speaking truth to
power even under threats to her safety
and extreme intimidation really seems to
me she took 130 grand from the President
of the United States and then has been
making a lot more money and a lot more
hay by talking about how one time she
had sex with him but she gets a key to
the city so there are lots of doctors
lawyers people doing great things I'm
sure humanitarians living in the living
in the West Hollywood area did any of
them got a key to the city no Stefanie
Daniels who has sex for money on camera
and then had sex with the President of
the United States when he was not
president but was married and it just
had a baby she is a class act she
deserves the key to the city I can't
imagine why people on the right don't
take the left seriously I can't imagine
why they don't take the left more
seriously I mean maybe it's cuz the left
doesn't take themselves seriously these
days already so we will be back here
tomorrow with all the latest i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire Ford
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018